got a news flash on the tour for all you
bozos and homies
though we're adding second shows over
there in Toronto and Denver tickets are
flying off the shelves and we added a
third show in Chicago scoop them up
don't get left out in the cold baby yeah
gang tickies are going quick we're also
going to be in Phoenix Salt Lake La San
Diego Washington D.C Pittsburgh Buffalo
Pontiac Michigan uh Minneapolis
Minnesota Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee
Wisconsin Sacramento California San
Francisco San Jose and Philadelphia well
that's for sure going to sell out soon
get those tickets we'll see you there we
love you gang scoop them up gang welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that at the group to be
classy yeah just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host stage Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at hoodies in the new edition baby
summer is in full swing she's out front
cracking open the fire hydrant okay
about to get arrested out there nice my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me unamused this week another
swinging a Miss from the big man
fair enough you take the good with the
bad he is the prince of Park Avenue but
always the king of the boards baby give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you're real I'm a
little nervous please make sure you
subscribe on it says full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are cooking baby and obviously
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it out over there oh yeah have a
nice quick shout out to our producer X
Jordan Air the magic man makes us all
look good works the ones the twos the
threes and the fours give it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dude listen it's not
often you get to meet the guy who's
responsible for your entire personality
this is pretty sick hahaha
freak out sitting you want to take full
credit but thank you very much
gang the long hair ain't lying cause
today we're not talking about incredible
today we are talking about greatness
today we're talking about Outsiders who
changed the game we're talking about
vert ramps and Big Air we're talking
about broken bones and broken hearts
we're talking about risking it all and
touching the sky because today we're
sitting down with the bird man give it
up for a true American original give it
up for Mr Tony Hawk everybody let's go
yeah let's go
thank you for coming very much
absolutely I'm honored this is great my
stepson miles was the one who alerted me
to your show and he's like you gotta go
on it you belong there it's just right
in your pocket I think it rolled in here
with a skateboard and a Big Gulp in his
house
we're going straight to the skatepark
from here had two kids get in this
building
buddy congrats on a new pod Mr Jason
Ellis Hawk first wolf thank you yeah I
heard you that Jason on here too so yeah
appreciate it we loved it man it's good
stuff give us the uh well documented but
give us the back story give it give us
the origin story you Mr Tony Hawk you're
a Cali kid right uh yeah it's San Diego
my dad was in the Navy
um and he retired in California and then
uh my siblings were much older when I
was born so I was a I was a happy
accident
right yeah I know I was an accident what
was the ace Gap uh my brother's 13 years
older than me and then my sisters are 18
and 20 years old
right there you're on the right you are
made for the show apparently Tony's on
the board baby what is your dad do in
the Navy uh he was a lieutenant
commander in World War II no oh [__]
yeah flew planes and well he was a pilot
what did he fly uh
I've seen photos of it if you showed me
a photo I could say yes that's the plane
holy [__] yeah on aircraft carrier on
aircraft carriers and what'd your mom do
um she was an educator she worked at a
high school okay and then uh when they
retired there my dad had a little uh
musical instrument import business okay
we sold to music stores and stuff okay
and I think he did that because my
sister was she had aspirations to be a
singer she became a great singer very
successful but
um he would do all their band stuff so
he'd like lug all their equipment and
then he just decided I'll just start
getting this stuff for cheap yeah and
selling it to retail shops but mostly to
get it cheap for the band for the band
yeah bam so the cutting Corners I like
your siblings were pretty much out of it
you were buying pretty much yeah it was
kind of like I grew up with grandparents
right right yeah with that yeah and
that's when started skateboarding and
um I played uh little league and
basketball okay and I was okay but I
never felt like I was really getting
better or aspiring to do much else and
then uh I found skating through my
brother because he was a surfer and
when I I mean I just use this
transportation and then one day I went
to the to the actual skate park that was
designated and they had these empty
swimming pools and I saw people flying
around I was like that this this is it
yeah this is the coolest [__] ever yeah
crazy is that bad yeah oh it's all right
that's nuts uh what was the name of the
street that you grew up on uh Escobar
Drive Escobar Drive yeah
all right talk about moving some weight
cocaine Boulevard I never even I've
never made that connection yeah we've
never made the Pablo Escobar connect
ever
Sophie El Chapo subdivision San Diego
[Laughter]
okay all right off to a good start yeah
very a single family home or apartment
condo uh it was single family home yeah
a lot of military families in that area
so he was stationed last stations in San
Diego and said we're staying here yeah
exactly gotcha so my my uh siblings had
to move around a little bit they were in
Florida and Northern California
California at some point my both my
parents are from Montana okay and then
um yeah and then we ended up in San
Diego and and they ran a I was not born
yet but they ran a little
um Beach snack bar really yeah
he was a hustler for sure I mean he grew
up very uh underprivileged and so when
he you know and it would they're they're
like children of the of the depression
sure my mom had two jobs you know and my
my dad was just trying to make ends meet
WW2 greatest Generation yeah he's always
on the hustle uh what was the name of
the grocery store that your mom went to
when you were a kid you remember uh
Alpha Beta Alpha Beta I don't think I've
ever heard of that that turned into
anything later on
or anything like that would it be
comparable to a route it would be like
Vaughn's okay all right I mean that's
Ralph's it's smaller though how are they
doing what did they do did they do well
when you were a kid like did they have a
little bit of money my parents yeah no
no
um they um
I think my mom's I don't know how she my
mom always had a spin on everything and
I think or later in life she said well
we you know we could have used a little
bit more
something like that sure but I made it
work sure all right let's put it this
way I remember there's there's little
flashes of remember but I remember my
mom coming home one day when my I think
my my brother was still in the house and
she had this look of dread she's like I
spent a hundred dollars on groceries
like it was yeah it was she was
devastated yeah like it was it was
trauma okay yeah all right all right
humble beginnings that's what we like to
hear uh what's the name of the high
school you went to
um I went to I went to a few but the
first high school I went to was Sarah
High School it was 8th through 12th
grade okay I was in eighth grade okay I
looked like I was in sixth grade okay so
I got bullied
um and then uh they moved to a different
part of San Diego and then I went to uh
San Diego High School AKA Santa ghetto
um
that was 9th through 12th okay and I was
hassled so much at that school that I
asked to be transferred to the nearest
school in the district
which was Torrey Pines which was also
more known for kids from La Jolla more
well to do gotcha um I didn't care I
just didn't want to be in San Diego
anymore uh so then I went there in 10th
Grade so I went to three different high
schools they bully you there
no I was more of a go I was they just
ignored me okay which is better which is
like one way better yeah yeah sure what
was that uh High School mascot do you
remember
Tory Pines Falcons
right that's respectable pretty good
right I like the Falcons what was the
pet situation growing up uh I had one
cat that went with me all the way up to
my adult life yeah no kid what was the
cat's name Zorro Zorro that's a good
time that's not bad I can't hate that
yeah I like Zorro uh what was the family
vacations like outside of traveling for
okay the one the the vacation I remember
the most like first one we ever took I
was probably five okay my dad put
everyone in the in the van hit a VW van
like straight 70s really yeah because he
could work on it too okay you know he's
one of those guys and uh drove us to the
tip of Baja California she
Mexico
and I seen I see pictures of this
vacation I was like how did he ever
it was but I just mean like it was no AC
no way sure super hot there's Q3 there's
no it was my brother and his friend both
my sister there were like seven of us in
this car that's like a bunch of hippies
of us like on the beach and these
strange sculptures and stuff damn
um and then the other trips we took it
was it was almost always road trips
um was like Yellowstone okay okay that's
nice Disneyland would you do Disneyland
only like birthdays okay had to be an
occasion never flying together as a
family once to Hawaii okay yeah that's
not bad yeah what island you go to
just straight like my dad wanted to see
Pearl Harbor gotcha Diamond it was just
all the tourists Waikiki Diamond Head
sure all right and I was down I mean
yeah of course uh how old were you when
you got your passport
um probably younger now that I think
about that I was no I think the first
time I traveled internationally I was
16 maybe
um I was actually already a pro skater
but uh you know most of the stuff we
were doing was just in sure in the U.S
sure and I got invited to do a
basically like a Wonder Kids TV show in
Tokyo first of all she went was Tokyo
yeah but this is funny because I just
realized this reason Tony Hawk super
terrific happens no it's supposed to be
14 and under
and I was 16 and I looked 14. yeah so
they said you have to lie about your age
on the show
really yeah Japanese TV don't mess
around like a Cuban baseball player
what's that yeah
and they made me they made me rename all
my skate chicks because they didn't
translate because all skate trucks have
strange names for sure and so they
probably had to call like one trick The
Floating Leaf and one what was that
supposed to be what was that uh What uh
that one was a fake yellow
Floating Leaf yeah which I get it's just
kind of just kind of drifts down and
then uh the hand plant you know when you
stand on one hand and we called an
invert or like a tuck knee uh that was
the monkey backdrop
I like that one better
that's out there you can see that Tony's
doing the monkey background yeah over
there doing the Fuji apple
all right that's all right yeah
um when was the first big check from
skateboarding
um do you remember do you remember my
first check okay was four dollars and 85
cents take that Dad can't buy much in
Tokyo or for a uh for a a signature
model okay so they sold five shows that
month and how does that develop from you
doing it not recreationally but you
trying to do it to you start to start to
become a pro what are your parents
thinking what are they saying are they
supportive about they're supportive yeah
my dad my I think I think that was very
sad yeah because he had such a rough
childhood he just leaned into whatever
his kids were into even if it was weird
so my brother surf my sister was a
singer like I said my brother became the
editor for magazine my sister ended up
singing for uh Michael Bolton among
entrepreneurs so it would accomplished
family it worked yeah um but when uh
when I started skating he saw this lack
of organization and and support for the
kids and he saw what it brought me in
terms of my sense of self and my you
know just my confidence level and so he
started an organization to sanction
skate events yeah yeah damn dude so that
was definitely supportive shout out to
the Hawks
what posters did you have on your wall
when you were a kid
like a young kid pre-skating I would say
um
I feel like I had a kiss poster
gentlemen okay
um
but I don't think I really I think once
I st once I started skating that was it
that was skating
pictures and stickers okay I get that
you remember your first concert the cars
really that's good damn where was it at
uh San Diego Sports Arena damn
pretty classy so far that my brother
took me to nice
any first jobs did you have did you have
a job that paper out you had a paper
route yeah okay do it in the bike on the
bike or did you walk I skate it
man
I forgot I just asked [__] Tony Hall
I suck I was yeah I mean I was I was I
just [__] ass Tony Hawk if he rode
his bike on his paper well but that's a
fair it might have you do it
kickflip wasn't wasn't even invented yet
oh my God you knew a backflip monkey
yeah
plenty of those holy [__] all right
yeah let's quit screwing around here
oh sorry you ever jump off a roof into a
pool
yes of course that was dumber than my
question my own my own you guys had a
pool no oh in the neighborhood community
pool okay all right and I remember my
mission as a kid was to swim all the way
across at lengthwise underwater and it
was like olympic size and you did it it
took me a lot I mean I would my mom said
she would watch me and she'd be like
he's going to drown was there a high
dive at this pool no no all right 70s
community pools played it real fast and
loose oh I know I wish yeah I wish there
had been high dives at three feet deep
and [__] like that yeah yeah it's like
working in the circus like a horse uh
you can take those off if you want it's
okay yeah whatever you're comfortable
with brother uh do you open your eyes
underwater yeah still do yeah
some people don't do it some people are
very anti do that in the ocean I do yeah
yeah you do it in a hot tub not duck
diving though do you guys know what duck
diving is yeah I've seen the north
shorts when you go underneath the weight
they're coming out I don't I don't open
my eyes duck diving just because I don't
want to get blasted with the foam sure
um what did you ask me what was the
other one the hot tub yeah yeah you're
the only guy I've ever I do it myself
you're the only other guy that opens his
eyes underwater in the hot tub I don't
know what gauge of garbage that is but
it's not classy
I don't know garbage either but the
[__] Kennedys ain't doing it
I don't have some some ulterior motive
by opening that
you do a little peeking
peeking that my mom's in the mountains
of the community hot tub that's what I'm
doing you know what they had a hot tub
in our community pool and they wouldn't
let us in it oh yeah of course there was
whatever
yeah they said it was bad for kids even
though they were just trying to keep the
kids out yeah you're under there when a
pair of bananas they're trying to get
creepy yeah a couple of swingers in
there trying to let loose uh what was
like a dinner like what at dinner time
the hawk household you know what was
that like could your mom cook
she cooked okay it wasn't it it wasn't
great okay I mean and and that is that's
just not from my judgment no I
understand my siblings as well okay
we're like Mom was not a girl did you
have a particular she would do spaghetti
with meat sauce okay
um but it it didn't have much tomato
flavor so it was just kind of going for
a Bolognese but I don't think that was
the entire shot there
yeah so I just remember sort of like
ground beef on noodles noodles okay
would you pack a lunch to school or
would you buy buy lunch at school uh
pack a lunch what would you usually take
um
kind of sandwich man yeah it was pyramid
jelly peanut butter and jelly when's the
last time you had a peanut butter and
jelly
uh I think I had one at my house in the
last year all right grape jelly
strawberry what are you strawberry
chunky peanut butter creamy
I like them both you do I usually buy
creamy though are you buying something
real real fancy are you going like Jeff
Skippy Jim really Jeff yeah only hawk
eating GIF white bread that crazy uh
wait wait now but back then all day
white yeah Wonder Bread will you wonder
bread family oh yeah okay Wonder Bread
SpaghettiOs
ain't nothing wrong with it did uh
Lieutenant Commander Hawk run a tight
ship at the house no like did your room
have to be clean no could you eat in
your room yeah yeah I mean it
um you know I'm Gen X like if Jordan
just left her own devices it was like
just keep him busy yeah keep them alive
or just stay out stay out until the
street lights come on you know yeah or
10 o'clock or whatever is there any
shows that you guys would watch together
as a family
we would watch 60 Minutes not like
because I wanted to I hated that dude
every Sunday
she heard that clock go and you're like
[__] yeah and watching
subjects and themes that I have no idea
what the [__] they're talking about
talking about the Iran contract yeah and
then what Andy Rooney would come on
you're like well that guy's kind of
funny yeah like I always thought he had
an attitude for being honest watch that
deal with it yeah but it was like the
only it was at least something humor
yeah for sure I do remember the the
thing that I got to watch with my debt
well let's see no we also watched uh
taxi cool together
um but the thing that he and I both
connected on that was like oh we're
gonna watch it would you remember police
squad of course no when police squad
came on that was like that was the
family precursor to the Naked Gun yeah
yeah good stuff was he all in a family
man do you like All in the Family yeah
okay he he was always in front of the TV
so I'm just trying to think of when when
I was you were also there yeah huh was
he a Beer Drinker do you like beer he
didn't drink really no I think because
of his his upbringing is that bringing
yeah gotcha uh were you a soda family
yes what were you rocking Pepsi coke
coke family yeah Coke at dinner
yeah all day really yeah would you have
milk with dinner
yeah sometimes okay yeah I remember
now you got now you got me going I
remember coming home from school so I'm
a latchkey kid right I come on no one's
home and I would make myself
uh a bowl of uh Captain Crunch
and then peanut butter original I'm
sorry original okay
um and then I would make my own cinnamon
toast
whoa go like make make the toast mix up
sugar and cinnamon a little butter
butter yep and a bowl of ice cream with
uh vanilla ice cream Hershey syrup and
then a little bit of milk so that I can
mix it up into my own milkshake that was
my after school snack all three of those
things in front of me damn
dude I and I I think back now like that
was just the most unhealthy thing I
could have done but back then it was
like this is the dream on a TV tray oh
watching Leave it to Beaver there you go
okay let's talk about Helix Helix baby
let's talk about the greatest mattress
ever invented and you could pick your
own I know depends on how you sleep you
go over there you take the quiz you see
if you sleep uh fat do you sleep hot do
you sleep cold what do you like he's
sleep bold what's going on you like a
California king like a queen like a twin
whatever you want they got you covered
deliver it right to your door stop
wasting time in a mattress store and get
on Helix yeah a little bit of this as
you know it's talking this week as I got
a new house putting the Helix in there
the boys you're sending one hit me up of
course what are you doing we're a helix
set in the city we're gonna be he looks
in a country maybe getting matched with
your perfect mattress is easy just take
the Helix leave quiz two three minutes
you're out the door whether you need
extra cushion for your spine cooling
features overheating Helix has you
covered baby here's the turkey Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two three pillows what for our listeners
those pillows are all right by the way
I'll tell you that go to helixsleep.com
garbage that's helixsleep.com garbage
there this is their best offer yet and
it won't last long gang get on board
with Helix get into bed with Helix
better sleep starts now do it okay let's
talk about butcher box
a bunch of box baby yeah one of our
faves gang everything's going up
everything's expensive these days I
gotta Stretch A Buck Isn't it nice you
know you get top Quality Meats delivered
right to your door throw them right in
the freezer I'm ready for when you want
to cook out do whatever with butcher box
we're talking wild caught we're talking
free reign free range we're talking
grass-fed grass finish beef we're
talking about top quality product here
we're both on it fridge full of meat
right now we break them out whenever
they're fantastic yeah level up your
nutrition this summer with cuts of meats
you can trust baby butcher box sells
humanely raise Cuts with no antibiotics
or added hormones take that to the bank
you can even customize your butcher box
uh so you'll be ready to make all your
favorite meals cooking will never be
easy I say let them pick though let them
Cindy it's great I know what they're
doing they know what moves let them
curate uh butcher box is giving us a
special deal sign up today hold on to
your socks boys I haven't read this yet
sign up today butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg and get New York strips
for a year plus twenty dollars
what are
they doing
butcher Fox because hold on start over
sign up today at butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get New York strips
for a year plus 20 off your first order
that's butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg
to claim this deal butcherbox.com
stop giving away my strips hit me up
these guys are gonna get mad at me but I
did that a couple a couple about a week
ago I got vanilla ice cream in the
Hershey syrup there's something about
that combo and you have to whip it up it
almost it tastes like it's like a
homemade frog it's unbelievable okay all
right I like this
um when you did start making some cash
skateboarding was as a young man was
there a silly
crazy purchase you buy yourself a jet
ski or anything like that over extend on
a car or something a date with Tony
catane or something I bought
um this is so dumb did you say a date
with Tony
could you buy It Weird Science which I'm
fully yes I would have yeah it had that
been available men yeah was that that
was like a Make-a-Wish thing oh why
can't I think of her name what's her
name in that
I can't pull it ah Rachel something oh
um no curly hair yeah Toby you got it
Lisa yes what's the actors yeah Lisa was
the character oh [__] my bad uh Kelly
LeBron
fantastic I remember seeing um Anthony
Michael Hall at an event when I started
to get invited to things like that sure
and he recognized me which I was stoked
but I was like Weird Science
yes he was literally a comedic genius
when he was a kid yeah shout out to
Anthony yeah 16 calibers yeah man but go
ahead big purchase oh uh
so my my I live near one of my older
sisters we together bought a tanning bed
you are trash
we live in San Diego
what year are we talking here
uh let's see uh well late 80s it would
have been like 87 yeah dude they were so
dangerous back then better off on the
sun no we went we bought a sharper image
which was the height of luxury oh yeah
right no it still lives that's what I
would do I would go like if I got a
decent paycheck because my paycheck was
all royalty based so sometimes it's up
here and sometimes down here so like oh
it's a good month I'd go there and get
like the newest small camera
and the best new headphones just uh and
it was all garbage like it was not like
it was the worst quality would you keep
the tanning bed at her house but I I it
was close enough that I would just go
use it like in her garage did you guys
use it a lot did it use it twice
do you remember how much it cost
probably about like 10 grand thousands
yeah for sure yeah also at 10 grand in
the 80s might as well be 4 mil
oh yeah yeah absolutely yeah that's
crazy I wanted to buy at the time I
wanted to buy uh our the arcade machine
720. and I couldn't get a deal on it
they wanted 12 grand for it and that
should have been my cool Ultra purchase
but I never bought one yeah this is the
coolest thing I've ever bought and now
it's out of order a big buck honey
machine I did I end up I Came Upon a 720
machine last year give you a good deal
on that yes very good deal yeah oh the
guy was trying to get rid of it because
he was taking a room in his house there
you go I was saying the Buck Hunter I'll
give you a good deal on that if you want
Oh but no no please get it out of here
I'm out five grand on it who was cutting
the hair when you were a kid
just go to regular Barber or your mom do
it
um I think my mom did it mom is doing it
in the kitchen
uh yep nice do you ever have a proper
bowl cut like oh yeah yeah yeah I've
plenty of photographic proof who's
cutting the hair now
uh who's cutting the Harris hair
established hairstyles they come to the
house or you go to them I go to them you
go to them all right
what's that run you
um about like 80 bucks
it's not bad well if it depends if she
does color okay I'm not hiding it like I
got I'm trying to cover this gray as
much as possible is that like a running
tab situation or is it like you go get
the haircut boom here you go yeah nice
uh what are you dropping on the tip
What's the total yeah uh 40 bucks you do
40. yeah all right so 120 out the door
yeah 120 yep right there it ain't bad at
all nice you doing all right tell you
that
I got a little bit of cash on you Tony
uh
do you consider yourself a bit of a
foodie I do now you do now because I saw
land I saw where you were the other day
at 11. yeah which is I think that's the
one thing that I will definitely splurge
on but also take advantage of whatever
celebrity I have accrued is love that
you heard about the show reservations
yeah yeah that's the ultimate right yeah
the fact that you're at a restaurant
that has a chef's table in the kitchen
yeah I know too yeah we're going to
atomics tomorrow
I want to say like number three
restaurant in the world right now okay
here in NYC how are you setting those
reservations up yeah you can't just call
me like Tony Hawk I'm serious I'm Tony
Hawk luckily uh friends that are
connected
my friend John Gray he runs ghetto
gastro he's my New York City Connection
so you call him
I went out with him and then like oh you
got a connection to Thomas of course he
does yes when you go out to dinner man
you're cool say you go out with a few of
your friends is it individual eating or
do you get like a bunch of apps to the
table and share it are you a shared food
guy
um yeah I yeah try everything yeah yeah
try I mean not everything it's not I
don't like being crazy wasteful no no
I'm saying like would you just get your
own appetizer no no I would be like no
we're getting all these okay yeah yeah
all right let's like uh we break on the
infield a little bit yeah we went
um I took one of my kids to this other
place here uh Tatiana which is another
highly rude restaurant anyone and we
went there I don't got a guy
I read about it like I'm I'm obsessed
sure but uh I I just pointed at the last
four appetizers like we won all these
hit me with them nice foreign
how do you get your steak cooked ah
medium medium yeah okay respectable
respectable it's not medium rare but
it's all right
it's all right you do I think I do
medium because a lot of times we're
getting stuff to go or it's in the
middle of stuff and then if it's medium
rare and it sits for at at any length of
time it starts running cold and rare I I
get that yeah Sushi guy you like sushi
yeah okay yeah and do you take leftovers
with you from the restaurant oh yeah
really yeah no kidding yeah wrap these
up we're taking them out yeah are you
walking out with them or do you get
somebody to carry them out walk out with
them all right
caddy
hey call up call James tell them to come
over here grab my leftovers and bring my
butter
fetch my onion rings uh okay well you
change the table will you ask for a
table change at a restaurant if you sit
down and you don't like it
do people do that sure I don't know I've
never once done that but you're getting
they're putting you in a nice spot okay
yeah yeah you're right you're correct
when you're at but I don't even I mean
we went to just some Diner this morning
there's no way we're in them no of
course New York City Diner I don't give
a [__] who you are
the Greeks don't like skateboarding all
right
I call cops now okay
um are you doing look at these nice
joints are they putting are they putting
in a private room in the back of your
little semi-private table um are you out
with the riffraff no that was a Riff
Raff yeah because you are obviously
everybody you know you're a very famous
person right at least I guess that means
you ask but uh I would but like you're
also a very uh man of the people at the
same time you're not you're very
approachable and everything yeah I
wouldn't want to be set apart like that
anyway damn that's what I want it feels
[__] put me in the back but it is
weird like with my wife she she isn't
she's not into the gluttony and we go
places and then they you know they get
excited and they'll send out a bunch of
stuff and then she just stares at me
like great yeah now I'm stuck here now
we're in this all this food how do you
feel about it you're like keeping coming
I get hyped yeah but we have we have
come to an agreement where if it if I
know it's going to be excessive
it's gonna be my own thing okay back on
gotcha God and that's fine we're we you
know we agreed to disagree on that do
you booze at all you drink yes you like
a nice glass of wine whiskey you like
whiz yeah what do you what's your goat
Do you have a go-to
oh man that's a loaded question
um hakushu-12 yes Japanese is that one
of your tricks
that's a good idea yeah is that okay so
all right I love the restaurant talk
here we go you sit down you're kicking
it off first of all is it is it is a
bottled water tap water or something
you're doing tap yeah I mean if there if
there's they just throw you the three
options then we usually go tap water
yeah really okay people okay and then
what can I get you to start you want
something something to drink you want
something from the bar you're getting a
glass a glass of whiskey yes are you
getting a cocktail with it or is it just
straight on the Rocks yeah
is that classy yes yeah I forget who
you're [__] this is [__] Mr Hawk
you asked him if you rode a bike what
are you talking about do you ever use
rollerblades
man I'm an idiot
all right so you kick it off with that
Danny Duty apps and you have dinner eat
dessert man you look a little sweet yeah
what do you like what's the poison uh
chocolate yeah I mean I'm not I'm not
picky I don't like cheesecake really
yeah well thanks for coming by
you just made a mortality I shouldn't
have said that
did I say I like I don't like all
cheesecake call security wait I don't
like most cheesecakes no and in that
situation
are you is it I'll have the chocolate
mousse she'll have to this or is it
spread out with a bite it is a bite of
that bite of that uh well generally
for instance the last person went they
just sent them out they're like we want
to send you guys sure desserts of course
thank you awesome yes and everybody just
tries but I usually I'm I'm usually the
guy if it's by choice I'll just ask them
what what do they recommend and will you
take so that when they brought out the
desserts on the house
and you didn't finish them you taking
those with you too or do you leave those
there
uh those are still travel yeah I don't
think we generally take the but they're
usually get eaten I mean it's almost
always there's a group of four or five
but if not that's a joke there's not
like let's play there's not the the
whatever decadent chocolate cake you
know with the ice cream none of that's
getting left okay none of that's getting
yeah if there's a bite or two left yeah
someone's taking someone's saying are
you a coffee man do you have an espresso
to finish off the meal uh yeah black
coffee yeah you do yeah okay no espresso
I don't know I don't usually get
espresso but I just I just like black
coffee I have a black coffee yeah okay
not bad respectable he's doing all right
if we went to your house right now hold
on go ahead sorry before we leave the
restaurant oh all right the culmination
of the restaurant oh here we go you're
out right are you picking up most
dinners yes right that's right he
couldn't get that out quick enough
who does it have to be yeah I don't know
who do you got to be with where where
they're getting who picks up a dinner
for you that's what I wanted that's what
who's who's grabbing the check and
saying uh the last one where agents and
my buddy John I told you who runs ghetto
gastro he okay but he knows he's gotta
be stealthy about it so he got up to go
to the bathroom and I was convinced he
was going to the bathroom because we
weren't even really finished and then he
came back
you're expecting to take care of this I
do yeah okay yeah I mean I feel like
that's one perk that I can you can share
with my success and I'm happy to like
I'd much rather have these social
experiences and and pay for them than to
have anyone worried that they can't
afford it no damn gentlemen so well put
um I ever split in the check multiple
credit cards only when people insist on
it okay I I usually just try to grab it
but you're not a fan of that no you're
obviously not sending venmo requests or
anything like that no you have a venmo
yeah you do yeah I get the funniest
requests
so funny I gotta I could share
I get them too people are like I'm real
jammed up send me 50 bucks
someone show up for doing this because
now I'll be able to try to find me but
let me see if I can find some of the
funnier ones
just laying on my first kickflip give me
50 bucks how do you find requests I need
12 Grand one guy requested five dollars
for big ass 900
this guy said fisherman fees you've been
eating a lot of commercially sourced
fish Tony that's bad for the oceans and
he wants to get paid you and yeah so pay
me Mr ocean uh this guy is the annual
Tony Hawk appreciation fee so I have to
pay him to appreciate me uh and the
other guy just said
sup man can you spot me five bucks
I respect it
gotta respect that all right all right
so we got the restaurant covered there
huh so now if we did go to your house
that's exhausting we were at your house
and you said you guys want a glass of
water what are we getting are we getting
from what do you have to offer from the
faucet are we getting a bottle are we
getting reverse awesome oh you would get
liquid death
because he's a company because I get him
free shout out to him I I have a
question for you he sent me they sent me
four cases every every month nice so
you've had a ton of sponsorship deals
like this what was the free Bagel Bites
situation back in the day uh what was
the the
I mean I was sponsored by them wait you
were sponsored by Bagel Bites yeah are
you our King that was that was my first
big corporate sponsor on my sort of
Second Wind of a career in the 90s
before before video games and stuff
that's wild did they send you some for
free yeah I know and I through the years
I still buy them
like I still buy them I I buy them
I buy them regularly for my for well for
all of our kids my daughter's 14 now she
still likes them so they still they're
still in the freezer okay um but I got
to do sort of a a revamped sponsorship
with them a couple years ago because
they knew I was still buying it
man to be that guy
would you consider yourself a Pop-Tart
or a Strudel man pop turret Pop-Tart
okay do you have a favorite Pop-Tart
flavor strawberry frosting yep okay dude
all right could you do you eat Pop-Tarts
without frosting I had to when I was a
kid we got the off-brand ones we got
toasters oh yeah they sucked yeah they
saw no we had yeah uh we're living large
real Pop-Tarts yeah frosting that was
one they were that was when they were
they were hitting too that's when they
dropped yeah aside from the bagel bite
do you have a go-to frozen pizza you
like or that you used to like
um uh Hot Pockets
all right hey buddy it's pretty trashy
that's very trashy yeah I like it
do they have a double pepperoni one I
don't know if I ever dabbled in the
double who's uh who's doing the grocery
shopping now and and where are you guys
you do mostly yeah where are you going
well that's the thing
my wife and I do it uh we we share in
the duties but she likes to go to much
more healthier stores sure you know more
don't sell Bagel Bites probably do not
yeah yes or Annie's off-brand like the
healthy yeah
and he's makes a pretty decent mac and
cheese yes but play off The Bagel Bites
though sure yeah like if you ain't you
know if it ain't broke don't fix it
gotcha so I go to Gelson's which is
basically right like a regular grocery
store yeah and I'm getting all the see
you on a Saturday walking around
Gelson's the shopping cart yeah [__]
nuts yeah
you can go there and ask him yeah he
comes in all the time
Deli Canada do you guys get like lunch
meat and stuff like that okay let's talk
about fitbot fitbot baby I got one right
here where where we're a couple of
gentlemen they're trying to turn things
around trying to get ourselves in shape
yep get fit bud you got a hot new app
over there helps you out helps you work
out lets you know what you got
customizes a workout to your needs and
to what you have in the house I know
it's fantastic which is pretty cool yeah
it's cheaper than a personal trainer a
great way is great way to ease in the
fitness lifestyle baby because I do that
when I jump in I'm like you know what
I'm gonna [__] do this every day
three times yeah I'm doing two a days
I'm 36 years old bald I'm trying to it
this guy's got four pelotons like an
idiot get fitbot I need one in each room
uh it's not too late to crush your
summer fitness goals baby and that's
what me and a big man are doing check it
out yes we are dropping lbs uh get 20
off your subscription or try the app
free at
fitbod.me slash garbage one more time
gang I'll get you get 20 off your
subscription
try it for free test it out 20 off your
subscription or try the app free at
fitbod.me slash garbage that's fitbot
f-i-t-b-o-d dot m e slash garbage do we
I just get the I just get the the
pre-package sliced yeah really yeah wait
a minute the like the like the Hillshire
yeah no kidding yeah huh you like it
sliced in
not thin no I mean
I I don't really that blows my mind I
can't get a reader you're not going to
the deli counter and saying give me a
pound of turkey and a pound of cheese
to the grocery section and getting yeah
I have a I have a like I have a line so
I know exactly if I'm going like he's in
a skateboard exactly yeah I gotta hit
the transfer and I'm going over I'm
getting getting these raisin bread he's
got a camera guy and a cart behind
kitten what kind of bread uh well I like
to get cinnamon raisin bread you know
the um yeah you do yeah since we're send
raisin toast
a lot of it goes to waste but I every
once in a while I get it so yeah it's
humble it's it's fantastic and then I
get the thin uh like wheat bread that's
my attempt at keeping it healthy sure
um and then I just go straight into the
like the orange juice yogurt and then
the front front Rock by the skim milk
yeah totally and then that one comes
right back around into the deli not the
deli the you know the the cold yeah the
pre-packaged Meats that's where the
security guard catches up with them and
chases them out
kids
um who's packing are you packing the
kids lunch
I used to yeah I mean my daughter she's
just she's self-sufficient now she's got
Apple pay she's got like and they have
they have lunches that she can buy at
school and she prefers that okay but but
I used to yeah
wow what's your go-to breakfast well
it's a typical breakfast for you
uh either that um uh the what is it the
oatmeal the um steel cut steel cut yeah
don't steal cut yeah all right either
that or uh or Corn Flakes or Frosted
Flakes really um yeah you're still
drinking soda yeah uh we usually have a
supply of coconut Coke you're eating
Frosted Flakes sometimes
then sometimes it's just like yogurt and
I'll put corn flakes on the yogurt okay
I mean this guy is my kind of guy what
about um if you're having like eggs how
would you normally have your eggs and do
you like eggs if I'm home scrambled yeah
I'm scrambled cheese cheese in them yeah
American uh yeah or cheddar all right
yeah it's like a 14 year old
he's sponsored by Bagel Bites
not anymore but I'm still hey I'm a free
agent now one let's run it back I'm
ready jump on pizza rolls like your own
Bloods and Crips yeah cheesy eggs and
cinnamon raisins yeah uh okay how many
suits do you own now
uh I have one one suit the one I got
married in yeah really I mean I have
I have another one but it's so old that
it would you know like if I really were
to bring it out people like dude
shoulder pads
do you know I don't know
holes in it yeah uh is it is it is it a
designer brand is it is it an expensive
suit uh yeah it's uh it's zenya I don't
even know what that is yes
okay I don't know you didn't get it at
today's man
I did not okay I got it actually I got
it from a friend of a friend who owns a
owns a suit for sure uh do you know how
to tie a tie
no
how many bathing suits do you own
bathing suits yeah just trunks yeah oh
uh I got like four okay do you wear
underwear under them no do they have
netting in them
yeah okay you know just board shorts
just three Bond yeah sure
okay
huh you got a pool at the house
yes hot tub yes connect it
it's connected yeah waterfall
uh yeah you mean like from the hot tub
into the pool yes not not like a actual
waterfall but no I got the same house
that was on Cribs most likely yeah yeah
it's a nice house salt water chlorine
pool chlorine chlorine yeah all right
anyone in your family Ever represent
themselves in court
I don't think so okay
uh who's caught in the grass you have
landscapers are you doing it yourself
yeah yeah any type of yard work or
gardening no on your end are you handy
around the house can you hand the
picture yeah yeah I get by yeah
I can't say that I'm I'm doing it in the
most professional way but but I make it
work I feel like skaters always are a
little bit because you're like your
ramps and everything it's very DIY yeah
and I learned a lot through building
ramps yeah of course yeah yeah you have
a go-to karaoke song
wow
I don't not really
I think uh that's a good thing yeah yeah
I don't know I was trying to think of
what my first karaoke song was I
remember saying
um uh
uh When Doves Fly
really get the party going with that
Jesus
yeah this is like mid 90s and they had
an MTV event and they had a big after
party and Steve Caballero who's also a
professional from that era he and I got
up and sang Windows fly I have no idea
why we chose that
okay huh but I'm not saying that's a
go-to because that was one and done sure
will you dance at a wedding
nah
I would prefer not to okay I mean my my
um my nephew got married here actually
uh in Brooklyn
last year and and I felt compelled that
yeah sure what are we talking Electric
Slide are we doing the Macarena or just
out there doing a little bit of actually
his bride is Russian and so they're
doing this very traditional okay that's
fun that's all right so I can't even
tell you what kind of music it was all
right but it got everyone moving
um
nephew's wedding what's a guy like you
drop it in the envelope on a on a on a
relative like that uh Lisa G
that's the right answer
Mr Hawk the Birdman yeah at least a g
that's a [__] gentleman right that is
that it's also like
the very gentleman responds because yeah
that's the mind wander I don't know what
it is but it's at least the G house yeah
I would feel like if I knew I gave them
less than that it would just be like I
picture your nephew at home right now I
would have checked for like 200 bucks
lying [__] ATM
he gave me a rebate they have a 400
limit I'm sorry I'm traveling gives him
a rebate for Bagel Bites okay okay now
is that a is that a checker that's a
good one actually
I did a whole promotion with Chipotle
and and there it was a kind of this this
I don't know how to explain it wasn't
really a direct promotion so they
couldn't necessarily give me a budget
for it so they gave me like a thousand
dollars in Chipotle cards nice
and I used that for Christmas gifts
like corporate gifts it was amazing of
course that's all right people were
Hypes yeah apparently there's a blood
there's like a black uh Chipotle card
that they give to I got one you do I do
yeah carp launch what's that you just
walk in it's it's supposed to be for a
burrito a day okay yeah it's and uh I I
don't have an army but it says Tony
Hawk's burrito card are you using that
I've used it maybe twice I've had it for
like five years okay huh it feels a
little pretentious that's what I've
heard I've heard people being like there
you go yeah and I've also presented it
because you know it's a flex obviously
and of course I was with a friend I was
like come on you got to use it I'm like
all right and the cashier's just like I
don't know what am I supposed to do
guacamole is Extra Man yeah exactly your
balance is 295. yeah yeah that don't
cover guac and chips but the manager
came over and was like oh yeah you gotta
put this code
dude I would be using give me a water
cup too and I'm putting soda in it I'd
be using it at restaurants and ball and
Ballers deflects on people yeah sorry
it's my lifetime burrito card I'll take
that back I used to have this was one of
the coolest things in the sort of 2000s
when when I had a bit of celebrity then
was
um uh I got a Wonka card
and this is before before social media
you know before everyone's really
connected on even on cell phones and it
was like call this number
and just say an address
and then we'll send you a grip of candy
damn so I would call it every couple
months and be like yep my address and
this giant box of different Wonka candy
would come it was it was the golden
ticket that day
or like a couple days later like next
day next day yeah man that's a hookup
right there that was pretty sick yeah
that's all right
uh huh what kind of car are you whipping
around in now
uh I have a lucid air
okay okay yeah that's the day today
yeah that's because it's got great range
so I'm I'm would you consider yourself a
car guy do you have you have multiple do
you have anything I have a 164 Corvette
that's pretty cool yeah that's the
opposite of an electric car yeah oh wait
but you know what I did I electrified it
did you what did yeah what are you Doc
Brown yeah that's right
a company that was doing that near my
area and I brought I brought it up to
them and they're like Well we'd love to
do it if you know we could do it for a
TV thing like yeah no problem so they
got they did it for um for Leno's yeah
so they and and actually it we talked
about them doing it they started the
process coveted hit it just everything
went South and then Leno called and they
got it done
man it was super cool electricity do
they do the thing where they put like a
speaker in it so it still makes the
engine sound not yet let's just say
they're still fine-tuning it it's been a
while okay
uh have you ever asked for a receipt at
a toll booth
no you got the Easy Pass right what's
that you got Easy Pass that's probably
not easy but uh it's fast tracking home
okay yeah all right what's uh what's a
family vacation look like now
where are you going what are you doing
it's usually tropical
um let's see the last vacation on the
last vacation we took last year we went
to Italy
and we went to this place that basically
you rent houses on the property but but
it's all part of more of a hotel
property so you can go you know to the
restaurant and sure sure but it was
definitely the the the Italian
experience okay
doing it right TSA pre-check I assume I
don't have it because not all of my kids
have it
so I travel with them a lot so I just
and I just haven't bothered you're
waiting in line you're taking your shoes
off what you're joking right no but I we
got the Chipotle card flash it Adam
but I'm using the first class line of
course all right that makes sense throw
you out of here if you want to fly in
first class yeah but honestly
the the first class line usually is
shorter than the TSA line
sometimes it is but you start to take
your shoes off I don't care about that
my shoes are either look at this it's no
problem you ever get to go into that
private thing where they where they have
stuff and where you're not waiting in
line concierge yes yes you do that uh
feeling that LAX a couple times yeah
private Suite yeah that's unreal yeah Mr
Chrysler talks about that a lot yeah
that place that's crazy do you have to
get him asked for that or do you you
have to pay through you gotta pay that's
crazy right are you a lounge man do you
enjoy a lounge uh if the layover is long
enough okay yeah otherwise will you grab
a bite to eat in the airport yeah yeah
okay McDonald's you're a very simple man
Mickey D's yeah you're a Mickey D's
cheeseburger no onions cheeseburger no
onions yes I don't know how I feel about
that really is that all you're doing
give me your typical Mickey D's order
cheeseburger and onion fries large iced
tea
unsweetened iced tea unsweetened huh
yeah just a cheeseburger Coke like if
I'm feeling not a quarter pounder
cheeseburger
I like that yeah I like the size and
that fills you up that's it I mean it's
an it's good enough for I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna get food on the plane okay
you know but that'll do no onions my
they're my favorite the diced onions and
Mickey D's I don't know it's just when I
was a kid that's all I would taste and
then that just triggered me every time
that makes sense uh with with the travel
when was the last year obviously first
class now when was the last time you
were in the van with like the team
oh
um that still happens
absolutely uh I was in just a couple
years ago in Vegas with the whole team
like we went uh we went to a uh a
backyard pool but it was it was a pool
in an apartment complex that was empty
skate it try to get some clips and some
photos and cops showed up and I managed
to get everyone out of the ticket yeah
dude but still that's awesome you're
still living it bro that's crazy yeah
dude [__] Slim Jim's in the back seat
Josh chasing you out yeah Clint came to
our show in Oklahoma City oh yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah Clint was on that trip
yeah he's the man damn yep huh that's
pretty have you ever been ghost hunting
no okay anybody in your family ever
claim to see UFO
no okay
have you ever bought the floor model of
an appliance or a TV yes
recently uh
yeah what really yeah what was it it was
something that was the only one I was
like yeah it's fine all right that makes
sense the only one you'll take like
we're talking like in the Best Buy Oh
you mean like they'll be like hey knock
off 200 bucks and I'll take you I did
get a discount on it they always give me
a Disney yeah
it was something fancy though it was
something like
oh man what was it it was it was so it
was like a it was like a product or
something okay something fancy where I
was like can we just get that one that's
the one we have okay we'll give you a
slight discount on it like we said it
was something that was like my wife and
I were you know they're making TVs now
no no no no no
yeah bro how poor are we we mentioned
restaurants and [__] suits I don't
know I just gave the Illuminati
skateboard TV
Louis Vuitton cars you don't know what's
going on over here
Gucci hot dog rolls what's going on yeah
what is the one thing you'll splurge on
you know designer like what you know
because you're you know you're wearing
very basic you know modest stuff you're
wearing your [__] birdhouse hoodie
and stuff
um I would uh are you like a watch guy
watches yeah I got into I got heavily
into watches to the point where I had to
get out really yeah because it was it's
just a rabbit hole don't they say it's a
potato always like retain their I don't
know some of them did okay most of them
went not so much and I'm not like taking
the greatest care of them so okay did
you have a Swatch watch back in the day
Shark watch anything like that Swatch
watch yeah yeah you ever have one of
those uh puka necklaces yeah Rock one of
those course okay yeah hook a necklace
and then he was the guy that wore one
that everybody else was trying to be the
way that's why I wore one that's why I
can't I was trying to be totally off at
school
it was basically you went to Hawaii to
proved you went to Hawaii sure okay so
when I went to Hawaii with my parents
that one time uh-huh yeah I came back
with it came back and then proof that
you have been to Tijuana is when you
were in a poncho okay
proof that I went to Wildwood New Jersey
shark tooth necklace
will you get cash back when you make a
purchase like let's say you go to CVS or
something like that you get a you pay
your car only rarely okay I I have but I
don't usually are you more of a debit
card man more of a credit card man
um I'm both you're both what kind of
what kind of plastic are you throwing
around you got an Amex
um I do but I just use my Visa my Bank
of America Visa most up most because I'm
I'm trying to get miles
[Music]
come on
it's because I've lived both sides of
that coin yeah you can't give it up you
know
are you using my are you yeah yeah
absolutely so what like to come here why
first class San Diego to Newark is 100
000 miles
and uh I had 300 000 on my account are
you booking the flights yourself like
you're going on uh if it's for PRI if
it's for personal yeah but if not if
it's for work it's for work it's usually
just you know it's the agency or
managers or somebody yeah
um let's step into the house for a
second I can't believe you're using mine
it's insane
um
you like to eat you like to cook at the
house too you guys like to cook no no
you doing family dinners
yeah but it's usually it's usually uh
delivery really like doordash or okay
GrubHub now will you guys sit down at
the table and eat or where you can eat
in front of the couch you can eat on the
couch
it depends it's it our kids are always
so scattered most of them are out of the
house now sure so if they're in town we
try to time it so everyone's there but
it's usually it's so hard it's like it's
like hurting cats yeah all right so
usually what happens is we get the food
I I get an abundance of food and then my
wife and I will sit and eat it and then
the boys will come in an hour later it's
already in the fridge or tear it up yeah
and then they heat it back up so that's
that's how it is well you take it out of
the packaging that it comes in and play
plate it or you eat it out of like the
container that it comes in
uh we usually played it yeah that's not
bad uh what are you drinking with dinner
at the house we have a soda we have an
iced tea we have
um yeah water or water yeah homemade
iced tea no no no the powder or like a
what's it usually I order it with the
feel okay okay fair enough were you a
Crystal Light family growing up you ever
mess with that no no Crystal Light
dominoes or Pizza Hut
huh
I'm not either one works for me you're
cool with it yeah are you an in and out
man yeah okay no onions no onions all
right uh thank you for that sure
I respect it this is another hot button
issue on the show uh you get out of the
shower you're getting dressed uh do you
put your socks and then pants or your
pants and then your socks pants and
socks
so underwear pants socks yeah when are
you putting the deodorant on
after the shirt or before the shirt uh I
don't know if I ever methodically
figured that one out like if it just
just happens when it happens when I get
to my toiletries or whatever then that's
when it happens do you know what
deodorant you're rocking what are you
using
um I have a John barbato stick you do
yep
counting points huh yeah I know what the
[__]
crazy you put anything in the hair you
get any product uh rarely
okay no I would say no are you peeing in
the shower are you peeing in the shower
yeah brush your teeth in there no in the
shower you got his and her sinks in the
bathroom yes is the tub separate from
the shower yes glass door on the shower
yep fountain or what's it called rain
coming down a waterfall we have both
okay you have both yeah do you each have
your own closets like you're like uh
yeah it's it's it's connected okay so
there's a lot of spillover sure but yes
we have our separate sides yeah they're
connected well it's just one long closet
and there's sort of a divider yeah
there's an imaginary divider sure king
size bed I assume California King
California King yeah you are I'm 16.
he's a [__] California
you want another water are you okay I'm
okay
um how many pillows are you using to
sleep I'm sure there's just one yeah you
sleeping on your side sleeping on your
back
on my back because my neck is kind of
Jackson no kidding you sleep on your
back yep huh is the TV on when you go to
sleep usually yes what are you usually
watching
uh if I mean if we're up that late
Colbert okay
um usually we're watching something that
was that we we recorded that was just a
series that we're gonna see I think the
last thing we were watching was uh Silo
okay and you fall asleep with the TV on
do you set the timer and it's off when
you wake up no it's just on when you
wake up yeah my wife will usually wake
up through the middle of night and put
something on you have books next to the
bed you're reading anything no I mean I
have a book next to the bat I don't read
it but I always look at it go man I
gotta get back into that
for the last two years that's what I'm
talking about
uh-huh what are you thinking Kippy
ah this is
he's way trashier than I imagined in a
great way but vexing to say the least
I'm cleaning trash sure right
I mean but he's got John varvato's
[__] deodorant
what's the refrigerator probably use the
mail-in rebate
get him a bottle of water
um what's the uh what's the fridge
situation is it a viking sub Z stainless
steel uh yeah it's Viking yeah Viking
yep same thing with the with the with
the range
we just redid our kitchen so it's it's
definitely not trash is it in is it in
the middle
like is it is it on an island we have an
island but the range is on the side okay
all right I think I'm pretty good here
man to be honest what kind of luggage
you got
not nothing special just whatever to me
um no I have a one I just someone they
gave it to me at some conference okay
it's super light and so I just run it
okay you check a bag
if I no try not to try not to yeah I've
had too many cases where my skateboard
doesn't make it sure so I carry my
skateboard on as my carry-on you can
like in your hand or in a bag in my hand
yeah so you so I'm sitting on a plane
Tony Hawk gets on he's got a skateboard
on his hand yeah always that's pretty
[__] cool man
it's crazy I have it here I know you
were all good with it can you whistle
with your fingers no you have magazines
in the bathroom
no
no no no I mean we have our phone so you
when you're in there you're on your
phone that's it yeah you know how to use
chopsticks yes hmm uh when it comes to
Wings do you prefer the flats or the or
the the
the the leg you don't care
do you have any two dollar bills
um
I had one not long ago because my friend
just gave it to me okay
so I probably still have it okay we're
not holding on to it being like this is
gonna be worth something someday
no okay
he has like a he has a whole
stockpile of them yeah people that's a
guy's trash people that think that
they're gonna be worth something yeah I
don't know but he gives them out like
here you go
if somebody if you're at a restaurant
and somebody's birthday is going on and
they're singing Happy Birthday will you
chime in and sing Happy Birthday
no will you give a round of applause
when they get done yes all right that's
the gentleman's room that's a
respectable move yeah
yeah pull you out there you need a lot
more than that
yeah I mean it's
he's like
I know you're trash but it's confusing
trash where do you keep the where do you
keep the butter in the house you keep it
on the counter you keep it in the fridge
uh the fridge keep it in the fridge
catch up
out there out not in the refrigerator no
interesting
man is it supposed to be in the fridge I
think so I think it's just refrigerated
after opening yeah oh well maybe it's in
the fridge I don't I never really
reached for the ketchup okay because
when we're getting stuff that requires
ketchup we're getting fast food that we
got the ketchup sure right what are you
dip in your fries in would you dip your
fries in mayo
are you opposed to it
no just ketchup just ketchup yeah okay
all right uh mayonnaise wise Hellman's
Hellman's or Miracle Whip
uh Miracle Whip Miracle Whip
who the [__] is this guy this is crazy
do we really like as mayonnaise is
something magical about mayonnaise yeah
mayonnaise that it really the helmets or
you might know it as Dukes or America's
best I don't see I don't even know what
those are the Miracle Whip yes Miracle
Whip man ah are you a mustard guy uh
yeah just regular mustard Golden's or
yellow yellow how do you like your hot
dog cook do you like it uh on the grill
boiled microwaved microwaved uh well if
I'm gonna get it I would hope it came
from the grill sure okay what are you
putting on it Ketchum mustard ketchup
and mustard yeah
but you really are like the poster child
for the suburban American yeah it really
is man it's funny I mean yeah I grew up
some regular kid in San Diego and going
you know the gnarliest dude in the world
my my dad our big like our big meal out
would be Bob's a big boy
like that's you're going family dinner
sure man listen as a fat
10 year old kid who wanted to be nothing
but a professional skateboarder and it's
crazy to sit down next to you and call
you trash but you're [__] trash yeah
I'm so happy
that's what that's what my kids were
hoping though
I mean the only way I could put your
every single thing I hoped you would be
and you talk about [__] delivering
man [__] fantastic oh 100 garbage
thank you so much on it this is surreal
for me I I didn't think I'd ever be
honored to be called garbage well I'm
happy to be the one to do it baby ladies
and gentlemen Mr Tony Hawk thank you
buddy uh you gotta put garbage you got
the podcast anything you want the folks
out there to know uh yeah Hawk versus
wolf we're on every week uh we got great
guests and uh I have a foundation the
skate park project
um that we we try to build we we helped
to build uh public skate parks under
third areas
um few here actually Brooklyn Banks okay
Les great
um and all class in that regard yeah and
the give and back section of course
that's amazing just one of the [__]
coolest guys yeah I don't want to be on
the podcast is your charity garbage
hahaha
that's our new spin-off
spin-off for for which I would defend to
the death that we are not garbage not at
all we actually have great ratings as a
charity and it's the work I'm most proud
of so that's amazing you can look it up
and you can help yeah it's crazy what
you've given back man it's really
unbelievable it's an honor to sit down
with you yeah man we can't thank you
enough we love you thank you we
appreciate it Kippy what do you got for
him oh guys we're all over the road
we're announcing uh second shows in
Toronto Denver and uh third show in
Chicago get those tickets they're moving
quick Philly's about to go
check it out Tony thank you again yeah
man that was fun I love you gang we love
you and we'll see you next week